this is mathematics for computer science
604 2 J 1806 - J a joint subject between
Electrical Engineering and computer
science and mathematics welcome
the instructors are professor Adam
chapala and professor Albert R Meyer and
I'm Albert hai-yah
quickly summarizing what this course is
about it's about the math that computer
scientists almost all need regularly and
which you're not likely to have come
across in your standard calculus classes
you may have seen some of this stuff in
high school for example in calculus
courses people talk about functions on
the real numbers and sometimes they'll
talk about functions on the complex
numbers but computer scientists are
usually dealing with much more abstract
functions on data types and even
functions on functions and I wonder how
many of you if I ask you to define
abstractly what a function was could
give that definition in a couple of
weeks in this class you'll be able to do
that with facility we will also be
talking about a variety of standard
discrete structures starting with the
numbers which we think of as a structure
because it's the numbers packaged with
the operations on them like plus and
times an exponentiation we'll also talk
about various other standard graphical
data structures like graphs and trees
and we'll look at methods for counting
the numbers of these different kinds of
data structures is a typical fundamental
problem in computer science where you
typically want to know how big is the
search space for example the search
space of passwords had better be large
or a cracker can just searching them all
to find one that works and finally we'll
talk about discrete probability theory
which is simply a version of probability
theory where we can get by with sums
instead of getting into the
complications of integrals so here's a
quick sanity check or vocabulary check
do you know what this great mates and
I'll give you a hint it doesn't mean
discrete if you don't know this is a
good moment to stop the video and
and up